All right.
Ginny Clark, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm doing great, Michael.
Thanks for having me.
No no.  Thank you
for being so generous with your time.
I really really appreciate it.
It's also very early.
So, I really appreciate you
taking the time for this.
Ginny, I can't wait to learn
all about your leadership experience,
your staffing experience
and the non-linear route that you took
to get to where you are
and the things you're passionate about.
Especially diversity in leadership
and in recruiting.
So, Ginny, why don't you take us back
to the early days.
Where do you come from?
And how do you get to be
a leadership staff there at Google
after doing
so many different other things?
Sure, I'm happy to.
It's an interesting story.
I've told it many times.
But I never get tired
of hearing it, actually.
So, I hope your audience
will appreciate it.
I grew up in Riverside, California.
I wanted to be a veterinarian,
so I went to UC Davis
to study animal science.
And after a couple of quarters
of studying that, I switched to French
and then literally
flip through the catalog
to fortify that.
And so, I landed on linguistics.
So, I got a degree in French linguistics.
I'd always been very active on campus,
worked in the chancellor's office,
peer advising, counseling, all that stuff.
And I took a job at the university
at UC Davis, as a recruiter.
Recruiting for the
University of California system.
I did that for two years.
And my dad really wanted me
to go to law school.
My brother did that, fortunately.
So, I went to business school.
And I go to Kellogg,
I moved to Chicago.
As a Californian, people were like,
"Why would you do that?"
It's cold.
I'm like,
Because I want to see [--].
You got their quotes for that, right?
I had the best time at Kellogg.
I was on their admissions committee.
As a first year student
I worked in the admissions office.
I was very active.
And then when I graduated,
they actually offered me a job
in admissions, which is
kind of like recruiting, right?
And I said,
"No no no. I have to go into business."
So, I went into banking
at what was then called first Chicago.
It's now Chase.
I spent a couple of years there and then
I got exposed to commercial real estate
and pivoted into commercial real estate
with what's now JLL,
used to be known as the South Partners
back in the day.
I did that for a few years.
Went over to Prudential
in their real estate investment
management arm.
And then my dad died
in the early '90s.
And that was one of those defining moments
where I just questioned everything
about what I had been doing.
And he had been,
I had amazing parents, both of them.
But he was really my coach.
He called me every Sunday morning
and cheer me on.
And so, after he passed, I just said,
"What is it that I've always
really loved to do?"
And I neglected to mention
that when I was working
for these other companies
that I actually went on site
to recruit for them.
I was not a recruiter,
but that's what I offered to do.
And so, I wrote a book
called Career Mapping.
And in the book I write,
I left a breadcrumbs for myself.
And so, I went back and said,
"I want to be an executive recruit."
I networked my way.
I was pretty good at it.
And I network my way
into one of the largest
executive search firm, Spencer Stuart,
and was there for 12 years.
And became a partner, co-founded
Leader Global Diversity Practice,
worked in financial services
and financial officer practices.
And I left in 2009 to write a book.
I wrote my book, did consulting.
Meanwhile, I have a son.
I got married and then divorced.
So, I've been a mom through all of this
and he's the light of my life.
And so, I did my own thing
for a number of years, about four years.
And then I went back.
I had to get him through college
and I wasn't getting
that Spencer Stuart salary,
so I decided to go
to another search firm that was in Canada,
this is where it gets really interesting.
That firms sold after about two years.
But one of the people that I had recruited
and worked with when the company sold
went to Google.
And in 2016, he called me and said,
"We need help because Google
had recently formed
their internal executive search firm
with people that I knew,
including this gentleman."
So, Ginny, just for context.
When you say search firm,
is that a company that is dedicated
to helping recruit people
for others? A seach firm?
Yes. A search firm at the executive level.
So, it's not like an agency
where we're trying to place people.
It's quite different.
It's much more
like management consulting
where we get paid a pretty hefty fee
to work with big companies,
mostly large, sometimes small startups,
and to find senior leadership talent.
So, what is the difference
between an agency that places people
in all sorts of positions
versus finding leadership talent?
Yeah.
What is the difference over there?
Well, it's much more of a,
how are we going
to describe this tactfully,
I don't want to impugn
any other agency.
But at the leadership level,
most of the people are passive.
So, it's not as though people
are applying for these jobs.
We get a mandate, we go out,
I would call on big companies
in the Chicago area
and all over the country to say,
"I understand you might be looking
for a chief financial officer."
And so, we'll spend time with them
to understand, well, what does that mean.
This isn't a one size fits all.
And we don't just post it
and wait and see who applies.
But we specifically do research
to identify what are the
other companies that are relevant,
who might those the correct people be
for us to consider to go after them
and woo them and pull them in.
So, it can be a lengthy
for a six month process,
sometimes much longer
to find those senior executives.
And that's what we do
inside of Google as well.
So, I guess it makes sense
because at the end, these are key people
that they could be
a make or break for the company.
A good hire may help the company.
A bad hire make may break the company,
especially the C-level
and above positions.
So, up until that point,
when you were in the two search firms,
were you the one going in
and getting that mandate?
Okay, we need a new CMO
and you're going out
to the market and say,
"Okay. Let me go pull in
the right candidate
until we can find the right one for you."
That's right. I did both things.
So, it's professional services.
And so, as I mentioned,
like in management consulting,
you have to go get the business.
You have to find the client
and then manage the client.
And then manage the engagement
with the, you've got a researcher,
typically, sometimes an analyst
who is doing a deep dive.
What are the companies,
who are the people,
what do we know,
who we've spoken to before,
this person might be great
in a larger organization
versus this one might be better
in more of a startup
that's got a build to it.
One thing that I'm assuming though
is that C-level executives,
especially the ones who are
right at the top of the ladder,
they don't go on LinkedIn they say,
I'm looking for my next opportunity.
Right?
They are in a great opportunity right now,
I might be wrong, but it sounds like
some of the gems are people
that are already have great positions
and so they're not actively looking.
And you have to understand
if they might be interested, right?
That's exactly right.
And when I started in the business,
LinkedIn didn't exist, actually.
So, now we do leverage it
because there are people
who will let you know
I'm looking for my next opportunity
or conversely people to reach out
to some of the executive search warrants.
I have lots of people
that will come to me and say,
"Hey, I'm looking for a job."
Which if I can pivot
just so slightly on that point,
that's one of the reasons
I wrote this book, Career Mapping.
It's because it concerned me
that so many people would come to me
as an executive recruiter.
Search firms are working.
They have an exclusive
on whatever that role is.
So it's meeting,
it's not a multiple listing service.
So, I'm not getting a view
of all the open roles for a CFO.
It's whatever my company
might be working on.
So, it worried me that people
would think about it that way.
And I thought
if I could help folks understand
that they own their careers
and that they should really be the ones
not just going to me as a recruiter
but I'm determining what they want,
then leverage me and others
to help get into that role,
into that company.
Amazing. What is the hardest challenge
of all this?
The most difficult part of this job?
You know what it is,
it's getting my clients.
I have clients within Google
or when I was with Spencer Stuart,
some of them my clients,
to really do an assessment
that is based on competency.
Because a lot of people
want to just default to
well, have they done it
in another company.
Right.
They might have done it really poorly.
And no one wants to say that, right?
Yeah.
But it's my job to tease out
how well did they do it.
And so, I ask competency based questions.
And so, it's not just,
did you do it?
Tell me how you did it.
Give me an example.
But then how do you evaluate that?
Because you're coming in
to all sorts of different businesses.
And I'm sure that within Google as well,
there's all sorts of different areas
which you're not an expert
and you're an expert
on leadership staffing.
How do you go in and help them
map out the competency questions
and evaluate objectively the candidates?
There must be some interaction
with the team that's hiring, right?
Oh, totally. Yeah.
And that's a great question.
At Spencer Stuart
and within Google, we specialize.
So, at Google I lead the non tech team.
So, I have people
who specialize in finance,
in marketing, in sales.
And that's all they do, right?
So, they really do get to know
the senior leadership market
and we stay in the market
identifying who is top talent
that we want to get to know
to the extent
we don't really know them
and have a relationship with them.
It's a relationship business
much more than it is for us.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Talk to me a little bit
about your expertise
in diversity staffing.
It's also something
that you're very passionate about.
What does that mean to you?
A lot of it goes back
to that competency assessment.
Because I think if you think about it,
corporate America
was not open to women
just not that long ago, right?
It hasn't been with Black Lives Matter,
I think we've realized
that a lot of black
and other underrepresented
racial minorities
have not been acknowledged.
We haven't always had
some of the educational requirements
to get in.
And so, it's important to me
that talent is being assessed fairly.
And that's really the cornerstone
of my efforts.
And that's the infrastructure
that I've sought to build
within Spencer Stuart
and even at Google.
That's really what it is.
And people, they look at me
as an African-American woman
and kind of say,
"Oh, well, you must know
a lot of black people."
"You must know a lot of Latinos
or a lot of women."
And that's not the point.
It's not who I know.
It's just who I can access
and I know how to access.
But I would much rather teach
my recruiters how to access
all of that great talent, right?
So, because that's pretty limited.
I can't know everybody.
That makes no sense.
So, to the extent I've got specialists
and that's what I've been able to do
with Google and a Spencer Stuart
was to build the infrastructure
that says,
"Do your research."
And I insist, our clients insist,
within Google and elsewhere
that we are showing them
a diverse pipeline of talent
that is relevant to the company.
Okay. So, I think
that's really an important point.
This idea that you're showing them
a diverse pipeline of talent
and which feeds them into the decision.
But then, what are the roadblocks
in the system right now?
What are the bottlenecks
that are making it very difficult
to do this properly?
Because obviously,
with Black Lives Matter and everything
that's been surfacing this year,
there isn't equality.
And I'm sure that in most areas,
the pipeline, the top of the funnel,
it still doesn't have the diversity.
So, where is the bottleneck right now?
Some of it is in identifying people.
I want to believe that my recruiters
are doing a great job
and we have metrics and tools
to monitor that.
I can go in and see,
are you meeting talent pool. Right?
We have to know,
you might say, for example,
I think black people in the United States
are roughly 12% of the population,
based on a lot
of the senior leadership roles
that we are seeking
that's not going to be our bogey.
Because we're requiring that people
have a certain level of education,
a certain level of experience.
So, the number is going to be smaller.
I won't tell you what it is,
but it's smaller, okay?
But we still have to identify
in that talent pool.
We're trying to get to a level
that makes sense at a minimum.
Because that's going to ensure,
that's going to give us
a better level of certainty
that we will indeed
increase representation over time.
The bottleneck is really one
of changing hearts and minds.
And so, I'm just going
to be real about this, right?
I can build the best infrastructure,
identify all these people,
put them in front of all
of these hiring managers,
but if they have it in their head
because they haven't seen a person
who looks like me doing what they do
during their experience,
it's hard for them to believe sometimes,
that person is going to be as good
as they need them to be.
And so, we're really trying to overcome
some of these latent beliefs.
I'm not going to say
these people are racists.
But I am saying that they've got
some deep down,
it's this notion of unconscious bias.
So, now more generally at a high level,
how does the ecosystem deal with that?
Because I'm sure this is something
that's recurring with every company.
And again, I don't think that
it's not necessarily
that people are racist,
it's that people have deep rooted
that through the years they grow
and they're watching certain personas
do certain things,
and then even subconsciously,
they have the cognitive bias
that when they're looking
at a few candidates,
still prefer the ones
that they're more familiar with,
that looks just a little bit
more like them, right?
Like what they're familiar with.
Right.
So, at a high level
how do you tackle that?
It's a part of what we're doing
is really tried to build in
some of the safeguards.
So, my recruiters are trained
to challenge them.
To the extent that they have done
the competency assessment
and they are convicted
that this individual is dequalified.
I have their back to go in and say,
"I got to challenge you."
Right?
There are other failsafes
along the process.
From the HR business partner
to my senior people
who are trying to monitor all of this.
And so, we're doing the best we can.
And there's a ton of training going on
for a lot of these hiring managers
and all these other people,
who are the people, the other interviewers
who are doing the work.
They're not professional recruiters
but they are part of the interview team
that might be working
within for the hiring manager.
We're doing lots of training for them
to understand not just competencies,
but this whole notion of unconscious bias.
Wow. So, you've obviously been
in several industries so far
and you've had various positions
that we spoke about earlier.
Why go into
senior leadership staffing, after all?
Where does this passion come from?
Give me that brief
from the book that you wrote.
Yeah. Well, I think it comes from
watching my dad.
He was a prison warden
and I watched a lot of young people
that were incarcerated
and because he was
with the youth authority.
So, a lot of these people were
as young as I was at one point, right?
And I saw the potential in them.
And I saw how there was systemic racism
in our justice system
that was causing some of them.
And they made bad decisions.
And so, I think there's
a little bit of that
in my mindset that says,
"I see the potential in people."
And so, I've always wanted to be able to
unlock some of the potential that I see.
I was drawn to the senior level work
because I have a passion for leadership.
I know that great leaders
make the difference in an organization.
We've all worked
with not so great leaders
and we felt it personally
and we watched the organization,
suffer might be an overstatement,
but not perform as well as it could
by virtue of the leader, right?
We're seeing that in government.
So, I think that's the other linkage
that I have. I'm really really passionate
about leadership.
And I think leadership
has a lot of different forms.
And that's part of the passion
that I have around
being an executive recruiter
and helping my clients see
what good, better and best looks like
even if it doesn't look like them.
I love it. So, as I go
on my own entrepreneurial journey
and a lot of my friends
who are watching this as they go
and perhaps to form
companies and businesses
and we'll have to choose the right people
to go on this journey with us,
whether it's at the start or at the end,
what are some of the key insights
that you've gained over the years,
assessing thousands of candidates
for senior level positions,
what should I be looking for
when I form a partnership
with my co executive directors
or chief financial officers in the future?
What are some things that I can,
as a bad recruiter that I'm right now,
what are some key things
that I can keep in my mind
that you've already learned?
Well, here's a real basic one,
Don't just tap your network.
Because I think that
that can be really limiting.
And frankly, it's a little bit egotistical
to think that I know everybody who's good.
No, you can't possibly.
We live in a vast world
and whatever you're building,
you should be able to tap people
in other countries.
Talent looks like everything.
There are brilliant people
all over the world.
So, make sure that you have
a real talent mindset,
and you appreciate and understand people,
you care about people,
the value they're bringing,
the uniqueness that they're bringing,
that to me is really critical.
And then, more tactically,
when you're assessing people
look for things like,
one of the most important things
that landed with me
after a couple of years
of being at Spencer Stuart
was self awareness.
I'd hear a lot of people saying,
"I did this, I did that."
And they were telling me what they did.
But again, they weren't telling me
how they did it.
How they did it. Right.
It seemed a little tone deaf in terms of,
it was all about me.
And then in contrast,
I would talk to people who
they would own the leadership
and they hold people accountable.
And they were able to talk about
their role in driving impact.
But they also talked about
the compassion, the empathy,
the awareness that they had
for other people,
for some of their own shortcomings.
That's a really attractive to me.
Because that to me is at the heart
of what true leadership represents.
I love it. Gi, 20 minutes go by so fast.
But I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important question.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And why you chose those three.
Okay. I was a linguist, right?
So, words really matter to me.
I want to go with bold.
I'm pretty fearless and bold,
much like my father.
I think I got that from him.
I am kind. I have a tough exterior,
but people who know me
know that I'm really really
kind at heart, big heart.
And then the last thing I would say
is awakened.
And by that I mean I have a very deep
and personal spiritual practice.
And I believe that I am,
maybe I should say, awakening.
You're never done.
But I've done a lot of work
to understand who I am,
what my purpose is in the world.
And I want to bring that
into everything that I do.
I love it. Is there room to be,
to have good optimism
regarding diversity and leadership
in the country over the next,
I guess, decade or so?
Yeah. I wouldn't do this work
if I wasn't optimistic.
I mean, there are bumps in the road,
but I think,
Black Lives Matter, for example,
is something that is here to stay.
I think there is an awareness
that there's a lot of work to do.
But I think those of us who get it
and are convicted, we'll see change.
Ginny, thank you very very much.
This was inspiring, truly.
Thank you for your generosity,
for your time, and continue doing
the amazing work that you're doing.
Thank you, Michael. You're a gem.
I really appreciate you.
Thank you. Thank you. Take care.
All right. Bye bye.